-Our next guest is a very funn
comedian.
Her critically-acclaimed special
"Nate: A One-Man Show"
is streaming on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
[ Laughter ]
[ Scattered laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-[ Nasally ] May I?
[ Loud laughter ]
-[ Quietly ] No.
-No?
-No.
-Alright.
[ Cheering ]
-Please welcome to the show,
Natalie Palamides.
How are you?
-Hey! What is up?
[ Laughing ] How's it going?
-Good.
I feel like for people who don't
know you, it must be
very jarring to go from
that clip
to see what you actually loo
like.
[ Chuckles ]
-I suppose so.
-It's very different.
People throw this around a lot
This is a --
This is genuinely fearless..
I mean that literally.
...performance.
Are you happy with the fact that
-- I feel like
it's coming out --
people are enjoying it?
You must miss performing live,
but is the feedback been nice?
-I really do, yeah.
The feedback has been nice
I expected to get cyberbullied
a bit more,
but, yeah, I'm glad that
that hasn't really happened.
Yeah, I'm really grateful.
I can't believe people like it
[ Laughs ]
-You're playing a character,
Nate.
Can you tell us a little bit -
how you would describe Nate to
people.
-I guess most simply would jus
say that Nate is
a douchebag with a heart o
gold.
You know.
-[ Laughing ] That really does
boil it down precisely.
This is a show about toxic
masculinity.
It's also -- As the clip showe
pretty well,
it's a show about consent.
I think these are ideas that are
tricky to approach
from a comic angle.
Did you appreciate as you
approached it
that this would be difficult
-Yes.
I mean initially,
I was just seeking to make
a show
exploring toxic masculinity,
but during the workshoppin
process, you know,
all the stuff about Harvey was
blowing up,
and I was like,
"I can't make a show
about toxic masculinity
and not address consent."
So I think it would've jus
stuck out like a sore thumb.
Like, how could you not addres
this?
So I was pretty timid to address
the subject matter,
when I was just -- you know,
'cause I'd just throw up stuff
on stage when I'm workshopping
a show.
I kind of just beat it out
have an outline,
and improvise my way through it.
I just slapped a warning on th
theater door
saying what kind of subjec
matter I was exploring
and then invited the audienc
to leave, you know,
if they ever felt uncomfortable,
to try to just relieve the
of the worry
of maybe offending me
if they were to
step out of the room.
-You know, as an audience for
show like this,
it does seem like part of th
fun is not knowing
what's gonna happen next.
One of the things in the special
is you wrestle an audience
member.
It goes well -- as well as tha
can be expected --
but I imagine on some nights i
didn't?
-Sure. Yeah, I mean, the guy i
the special, Noah --
bless him --
he just crushes it.
Yeah, and you know, I have t
kind of feel it out
each time I bring
a new person on stage.
Sometimes they don't really want
to wrestle me at all.
So I'll just have them hold my
arm behind my back
and do some stage combat
kind of stuff
where I throw myself down
on the mat,
and that becomes a joke within
itself
'cause the audience can se
this person's not doing anything
to me but I'm screaming an
saying, like,
"[ As Nate ] Leave me alone!
You know, anyway.
-One of the things I feel like
we're all going through no
as we watch stand-up special
and it makes you long for
a time where it was safe to be
in a theater,
laughing out loud,
sort of projecting our breat
everywhere.
This show, I mean, it's
everything.
You're serving drinks, you'r
wrestling with people,
you're in the audience.
Does it feel weird to watch it
now or does it just make you
long for time when you can do it
again?
-Oh...
A little bit of both.
I'm really kicking myself.
I'm like, "Nat,
can't you come up with any
material where you don't
freaking touch somebody?"
-[ Laughs ]
-'Cause I'm like, "When am I
gonna get to do any sort of bits
after this whole thing
lets up?"
But yeah, it is jarring watching
everybody without masks.
I was even watching
"The Queen's Gambit"
the other night and I was
a little bit startled
when I would forget that,
you know,
it's not current times.
I was just like,
"They're not wearing masks."
-"Really, somebody else
just touched that chess piece.
You shouldn't be putting you
hands on that."
-Exactly.
-I read that your brother wa
a wrestler
and you actually would
practice with him.
Did you then feel --
Was it important for you to show
it to him and did he enjoy it?
-Yes.
It was very important for me
for him to see the show.
And I actually tricked him int
seeing it
because he had found out m
boobies were out
as Nate and he's like,
"[ Gruffly ] I'm not watchin
that," or whatever.
So I invited him to see a
10-minute set
that I was gonna do
at a stand-up show,
and he's like, "You're not doing
'Nate' are you?"
And I was like, "No, no, no, no.
Don't worry.
I'm doing this fairy godmother
character tonight.
And so he's like, "Alright,"
rocks up to the show,
of course I do "Nate"
'cause I just wanted
to rip the Band-Aid off
and I wanted him to see th
whole show
'cause I knew he would enjoy it.
Yeah, I did "Nate" for him tha
night, and he liked it.
But to get me back after
that show,
he smashed a piece of cake
in my face.
-Well, that's only fair.
I mean,
that's just sibling stuff righ
there.
-Exactly.
It's all fair, you know.
But yeah, he would pay me in
packs of gum as a kid
to try out new wrestling moves
on me
whenever he was learning new
moves.
-Well, it's very nice, then.
It seems like a nice cycle
between you guys
of being able to trade
institutional knowledge
back and forth.
-Truly.
We have fun.
He's the best.
-Hey, thanks so much for being
here.
Congrats on the special.
It's really...
It is exactly that --
It is really special
and different, and you should be
really proud of it.
-Thanks so much, Seth.
I really appreciate it.
-"Nate" is a one-man show.
It is streaming on Netflix